[Aplausos]
italia sofocada por el calor en
lombardía las altas temperaturas están
causando la peor sequía en 70 años
afectando a los cultivos de arroz del
llamado triángulo de oro tardío vicini
es dueño de esta finca ubicada en las
llanuras delpo en la ciudad de tcm
estima que sus ingresos se han
desplomado entre un 80 y 90 por ciento
por culpa de la sequía
sorprendido puede recorrer en moto sus
arrozales debido a que la sequía no ha
permitido que el arroz crezca lo
suficiente
normalmente las plantas deberían llegar
a mi rodilla y el arrozal se inundaría
pero este año este arroz al nunca se ha
regado porque la cantidad de agua
necesaria para regar todos los campos de
mi finca nunca llegó al bar juanito
abajo a darío le preocupa que el
crecimiento del único rosal regado por
el agua tiene un mes y medio de retraso
la situación es preocupante
italia exporta el 60 por ciento de su
arroz por lo que las afectaciones en los
arrozales de darío se sentirán más allá
de las fronteras italianas el triángulo
de oro principal región productora de
arroz en europa asia ves que existe el
riesgo de perder la tradición arrocera
de esta región que es una gran fortaleza
de la industria agroalimentaria italiana
no hay que olvidar que somos los
primeros productores de arroz en europa
el consumo de arroz en italia se
incrementó durante la pandemia
actualmente el país produce 1.5 millones
de toneladas y hay más de 200 variedades
entre las cuales están carnaroli arborio
romá y valdo famosos en la preparación
de platos típicos de risotto darío y
otros arroceros italianos están a merced
del clima se espera que las temperaturas
sigan siendo altas en medio de la ola de
calor que atraviesa el sur europeo este
sábado en lombardía el termómetro
alcanzó 34 grados celsius a comienzos de
julio italia decretó el estado de
emergencia por la intensa sequía